we're moving from November into December
and video games are coming with us this
week's new releases run the gamut of
epic RPGs to snowboarding to talking
food let's get to it over a decade in
the making Final Fantasy 15 is finally
launching on ps4 and Xbox one this tale
is all about Prince Noctis and the
journey he takes with his buddies it's
equal parts road trip open world
exploration and intense combat and since
it's a final fantasy game I don't even
need to mention the array of spells and
some ends and weapons and quests you'll
encounter the delays are finally over
and you'll be able to start your grand
adventure on Tuesday November 29th I
know what you're thinking and you're
right there is a severe lack of pc games
about sentient talking vegetables that's
where Mays comes in it's a first-person
adventure game about scientists who
accidentally create talking stalks of
corn and according to developer finish
line games that's the least ridiculous
thing about it you can explore the farm
research lab and other crazy places on
December first if you're looking for a
new tactical RPG to take on then you'll
probably be into the dwarves based on a
German fantasy novel this tactics game
sends a squad of warriors through a
bunch of medieval environments like
dungeons and fields and mountains
battling big monsters with all sorts of
weapons if you're tired of all those
tall lanky elves and humans doing all
the work and the dwarves should be a
nice change of pace it's coming to ps4
xbox one and pc on december first last
year's smash hit is moving from the wii
u to the 3ds the handheld version of
Super Mario maker works a bit
differently from its console cousin
you'll still be able to create and play
custom courses but this time you'll
share them via streetpass and even
collaborate on levels with friends you
can't upload your creations online but
you can grab a celeb
of courses from the wii u version and
play them on the go you can start
building the level of your dreams or
nightmares on December second last but
certainly not least steep is the perfect
way to kick back and go crazy with some
extreme sports the world is lined with
snowy mountains and rocky peaks and you
can speed down them on snowboards sip
around them in wingsuits or fly around
them in paragliders more races and zones
will unlock as you complete challenges
so if you can't make it to the family
ski trip this year steep looks like a
good substitute you can pull off some
sick tricks on ps4 xbox one and pc on
December second and those are the big
games coming out this week with a little
something for everybody as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for tuning in guys and
I'll see you next week